oh yes Seattle has wonder so there's
that and I want to hear more about
Seattle because you know we hear about
regional filmmaking all over the country
but but what if what if you're just by
yourself and there is no community to
jump into I made sure like like how did
this come about for you and what about
someone that's maybe in in Michigan that
that has nobody how would they how would
they go about getting started I think
for us it was film school but I don't
necessarily say think that everyone else
go to film school but it's using your
your like-minded friends that you have
around just start with I think everyone
has a community if you just it just it
may be defined differently so for us it
started in film school yeah that group
yeah absolutely completely agree because
I mean the people some of the people who
have been in film school like we use in
our for a short we use in the first
feature then we use on our second
feature you know so they're definitely
carried through but i think you know at
least so in seattle there's this there's
this idea of the seattle freeze that
like if you're new to the town or
whatever people can put very standoffish
and stuff but in the film community for
some reason that doesn't really happen
like if you go to a mixer or a
networking event which the city actually
hosts every month there's a there's a
huge mixer you can go up and talk to
anybody and just if you've made good
work people will want to work with you
like it's women literally found people
we we've gone to those mixers looking
for specific people you work with yeah
and that then worked with them so you
know I know where we go there and then
also at the same time before I was
founded I spent a year when we first met
moved to Seattle and had our film
company I mean we literally work by
ourselves cuz we move to a city that we
didn't have met her parents we did cuz
you know Chris kind of grew up in that
area but we didn't have like a full
community and we were total newbies so I
became a member of the Chamber I became
a member of our local Chamber I became a
member of every group I possibly and
just started networking
and we just never knew where it would
take us and so we did some corporate
things and that kind of like then
introduced us to other people doing
corporate things that were also then
artists and then you know and it kind of
goes from there so it's just literally
not uniformly go out dr. yeah right and
then go ahead that's the one we went to
our local film festival went to the q
and A's talk to the people you know the
filmmakers that we're doing things in
Seattle and that's how we became friends
with Lynn Shelton and Megan Griffiths
and Lacey Lovitt or the you know big uns
in Seattle right now and that's how we
met John Jacobson and Rick Stevenson and
you know people run the film school and
you're doing bigger things so you just
have to so yeah my natural tendency to
have social anxiety problems is not good
but she just laughs that so so I just
talked about how awesome he is and I
just I just drink in the corner and it's
fine it works out and I find you know a
super geeky guy person that will that
will time they geek out and oh then I go
and I miss them I get little nerd
playdates and it's fine check
you